what's better what's better a stranger
spends 10 hours a day with your kid or
the mother spends 10 hours a day with
your kids
you're spending 10 hours a day with
people your age
I'm just gonna repeat the question is
what is better a mother spending 10
hours a day with her child or a stranger
spending 10 hours a day I'm gonna be a
stranger because you're in school as I
think her it is a stranger
I think it's good I think school is good
I don't think it's not black and white I
don't think school is good at all I
think the system's failed like a long
time ago the whole point is that you're
allowing a stranger to have more
influence over your kid than you do and
we see it you see it constantly where
these kids come out super left when they
come from conservative home oh yeah